[Applause]
thank you
there are some areas where labor had to
do well to prove they're on the comeback
Buxton is one of those places
[Applause]
labor gained seven seats here the
conservatives lost six it's not the
runaway Victory labor would have liked
but it's a win for them before the
election no single party was in overall
control in this area although labor did
have the majority of seats and speaking
to people in this town there's
definitely a sense of apathy even
weariness towards the conservatives but
labor know that support for them isn't a
sure-run thing either
there's a lot of apathy here Charis and
Daryl they decided not to vote this time
nothing ever comes of what they say
anyway in the first place really does it
so yeah it's a bit sad all that wasn't
it because you could take an active part
you could put your cross on the box you
could see like I want you in I want you
out
I just don't really think it makes much
of a difference so nothing would have
sort of spurred you on to going on you
know what I need to vote no not really
to be honest yeah no
so how did you vote none of the above
I've spoiled the paper deliberately so
you got your postal vote you've got your
pencil out and you just wrecked it yeah
to make a point yes and what is that
point that you're trying to make don't
want any of them
but those people who did vote like
Rachel who's voted for all the main
parties in the past says she wants
something new now obviously the current
government isn't working as it is
um you know with the cost of living
everything's going up isn't it and as a
a parent of a young child as well I
worry about the future and how he's
going to grow up
um so yeah just for change really
and the borders of Buxton could give us
a glimpse of what might happen during a
general election Dawn voted liberal
Democrats this time you don't like
conservatives at all I don't think that
they are
um
thinking about people that are
struggling to have no money that are
really really struggling on the
breadline and the labor I'm a bit
disappointed with kirst Alma do you
think that would sort of extend to a
general election the way you feel in a
general election I would feel like
voting labor to get conservatives out
so it's a bit of a tactical vote
these semi-rural areas have suffered
with Rising fuel costs and the lack of
affordable housing and the politics here
is finally balanced Nick Martin Sky News
Buxton